do you guys see this tweet we have this
from gordon leubold all right this guy
is a white house national security
pentagon reporter for the wall street
journal yeah he says leon panetta says
on cnn that biden's gaffe in europe
about regime change came about because
biden is irish what and his instinct to
internalize human suffering may have
overwhelmed him to the point where he
was not careful about what he says biden
needs more discipline panetta says
what's he talking about what do you
think is he saying there's some sort of
internalized irish thing that exists
within ethnically irish people causes
them to respond a certain way alex are
you irish i'm not irish oh okay well i i
could self-identify though yeah that's
exactly that's true all right well i did
on the 17th yeah wait this is i'm
assuming this is satirical though
you're sitting right i'm going to be ian
tell me about this deep irish uh
internalization of suffering wait i want
to be clear this is a joke right no
no come on
are you serious oh my gosh i would have
used this to get out of so much trouble
in school i know right i've been like
you know what i'll turn my homework in
when uh ireland is a free nation not
being occupied by the british is that
what they're claiming yeah i have no
clue what what is this
i'm sorry
this is this has to be a joke you're
messing with me i don't know is it a
joke is it for real i don't know it's
this is a wall street journal reporter
tweeting it out i i agree with you i'd
assume it you know even if it's not a
joke it's a joke you know what i mean
yeah it's ridiculous it's a great
statement i mean
the spin's amazing are we an oppressed
group now who gets to use that as is
like an excuse for failure the irish
have always been oppressed in my opinion
it's true well no i mean irish people
weren't like considered white until
being white meant you had to apologize
for being white absolutely so frankly
you know talk about uh preparation
buying high and selling low i'm just
thinking about how we're going to title
this thumbnail like this clip and it's
going to be like sheamus outrage
responds outrage to racism i guess cnn
claims joe biden is oppressed because
he's irish yes or something like that
it's gonna be good i don't but i wrote a
book called anglo-fragility and it's
about how
if you don't think you have anglo
privilege it's because you've
internalized it more deeply than other
people and when i make mistakes and you
point that out it's actually because you
are spitting upon the graves of my
ancestors for holding me accountable
irish i didn't see that one coming yeah
i can't believe that that is it would be
really great if they used an excuse for
anything biden does he's irish come on
so this is remember well this is
interesting cause you remember during
the state of the union when i said he
sounds
drunk oh he's irish
you brought up a good point about the
russiagate scenario as well and and it's
important lindsey graham was on cnn
shortly after the 2020 uh 2016 election
and he did an interview talking about
how russia also hacked his emails and
that's why he got one percent of the
primary vote now he got one percent of
the primary vote because his failed
dangerous policies were horrible and
widely rejected and also because he's
lindsey graham nobody likes this guy and
so he's had a personal bone to pick with
putin for a long time he blames his own
failures on on putin he should take some
self-accountability and seek help i want
to make two points here firstly everyone
argues well my emails were hacked by a
nefarious group who you shouldn't trust
okay but those were your emails we're
talking about things you actually said
you can't like putin did not put those
words in your mouth but also we went
from the president as a russian puppet
to the president is an irish puppet his
internalized uh suffering as an irishman
irish gate that's resulted remember when
someone someone commented is this really
the country is that not also like really
really offensive that's extremely racist
towards he isn't
i know but that's extremely like oh well
of course he's going to make mistakes
he's hiring you know like a horse of
course he said something ridiculous and
needlessly aggressive that he didn't
need of course he picked a fight that he
didn't need to get in his iris whenever
whenever biden slurs or stumbles can we
just say he's irish he's irish
you know what the implication of that
would be but look look look someone
replied is this related somehow to
cuomo's i'm irish defense
that was cuomo's italian defense yeah
when he posted all those videos of him
grabbing people and kissing them and he
was like see look it's normal i do it
all the time that's what the top comment
is an italian giving advice on
self-discipline question mark question
mark yeah are you guys here this is not
a joke um fox just released an article
that says former obama defense secretary
president biden made putin gaffe because
he's quote irish please hold on can you
can i read this tweet again i'm sorry
i'm not off this yet but
we'll get back to it don't worry
oh there we go so we got the actual
article i mean this is what can you
expect from him i know he's just irish
yeah there you go
he strikes again oh my god it's amazing
new epigenetic trauma is a mainstream
smart person concept data point just
dropped
all right um
joe biden is in europe
making gaff after gaf
implying that u.s troops would be in
ukraine the white house then goes no no
no no no
then saying if putin uses chemical
weapons we respond in kind no no no no
no
then he says we need regime change you
know what i'll i'll take it and then
they're like
cnn then comes out this time at the
white house oh it's cause he's irish and
he's internalizing the suffering of the
ukrainian people he's like his sweet
little irish feelings were too
overwhelming to him he's not in control
of himself is it is this like a point no
no no no no no no no for real like a
serious question though is is are they
making some kind of point about ukraine
being like northern ireland like the
donbass region is northern ireland and
russia is like the uk you know what i
mean i think they're just calling irish
people stupid yeah
i'm pretty sure that's what's happening
here they're like look joe biden joe
biden doesn't have dementia he's irish
that's what's happening right now do you
understand shame he's a crazy victim to
be a victim no well look this guy is
giving me victim points he's saying that
irish people are more likely to
internalize other people's suffering
yeah i mean it makes it sound like very
nice and empathetic i get that but
it's i don't know a little bit offensive
you know oh by the way i'm trying to
make myself a victim tim every single
time you say something insulting about
the irish people you you pull the irish
card out and say oh i'm part irish dude
so really tim you're being insulted as
well what am i i think i'm like a third
irish or something
i'm german so
you know no empathy there yeah no
empathy from me
no empathy for me i am german irish and
korean and there's like uh and like a
little bit of a bunch of stuff like my
last name is dutch i guess
but uh yeah absolutely i'm wondering
it's like the germans and the irish like
team up for something because like
german irish tends to be like that i
mean we both drink drinking beer germany
is actually a pretty common mix yeah
german people and irish people were like
yeah i think those were just i think
those were just like the poor immigrants
at the turn of the century yeah right
that sounds like the 1900s late 1800s it
was the irish of the germans and they
hung out and
but no i think there's something i do
think there's something to this there do
you guys remember biden's whole like
pot of gold gaff
we're gonna pay off of course we're
gonna be able to pay off the national
debt we've got free punch of gold at the
other end of the rainbow his economic
plan to follow rainbows until we could
get the gold at the end of them do you
guys not recall yeah
yeah yes exactly
there was uh no no no no
in all seriousness though there was that
one moment where he was chasing after
all those little kids yeah because uh
that's right because he sniffs them he
said they're after me lucky charms no i
wasn't going i actually wasn't going for
that joke i was going for the biden
sniffs little kids really it's not a
joke it's a real problem
that should not be tolerated is it not
i'll leave it alone in a second because
i know we've really harped on this but i
just gotta say is it that hard to admit
the man's experiencing cognitive decline
he makes a gaffe because he always makes
gaffes and they're like you know what
the guy's irish because yeah you know
or always
leon panetta is like
biting gaffes and they're just looking
in the hat of random defenses of biden
and there's like one left and says irish
on he's like
cause he's wish me luck
well i think it's important to remember
that obama's former secretary of defense
robert gates said quote biden's been
wrong in every foreign policy decision
in his entire career and so there's
there's no excuses for the guy just
sucks at his job he's been in office for
50 years and he's been wrong on
everything and so nobody has confidence
in his ability to get us through that i
got to push back on that man uh that is
that is unfair
biden has not been wrong on every
foreign policy decision he's made uh
incredibly uh successful decisions as it
pertains to foreign policy for his
family oh yeah you know the contract is
brother god i gotta say like like arming
the irish rebels
the job yeah the jobs that his uh his
kid
got uh i think i think you're looking at
the wrong place you're right so we can
say that joe biden has failed the
american people in terms of foreign
policy but the joe biden personal family
foreign policy is quite successful i
mean to be honest though i could not i
could not believe it when he armed the
ira yeah
really i thought that was pushed too far
it was very shocking it's funny but like
i am that sounds like something that
could be true actually because he's been
in office for so long like actually in
the late 80s early 90s biden signed this
bill
stated he's like come on man we're gonna
give could have gone guns the ira man
get ready get rid of the brits
i got a brand new shiny helmet and a
pair of kinky boots man but i don't
remember the last presidential election
where foreign policy wasn't really at
the forefront yeah and because of
president trump's success for four years
we had peace all across the board peace
in the middle east peace in korea uh you
know russia was at bay china was
obviously doing what th what they do to
you know unleash the virus under the
world uh but the foreign policy aspect
wasn't really a conversation during the
2016 2020 debate when it was at the
forefront of the 2016 one but who's
going to destroy isis and everybody
thought that trump was going to be the
one that actually did it and he
succeeded uh but this is in foreign
policy was a negligent issue in the 2020
debate and if you could have played that
clip of robert gates saying that he's
been wrong on every foreign policy
decision and there's actually foreign
policy conflicts i think that would have
had a a you know drastic impact but
we're seeing the genius at work here and
and what happened in afghanistan what's
happened in ukraine china is going to
move on taiwan it's going to be nasty
and we got this blabber and fool in the
office and hunter biden's you know
secure in the bag they suspended the gas
tax
so a bunch of people i've talked to
people out here in maryland and they're
like
uh they're like no gas prices went down
things got better and i was like yeah
they suspended the gas tax like gas
prices aren't going down the government
just backed off because they're scared
about what's happening and they went oh
they're like yeah because in west
virginia it's still over four dollars
but but don't worry
biden brought in the tick dockers to say
to make tick tocks calling it the putin
gas hike or gas price hike so it's on
putin he says and they all come in like
good little sheep and then they you know
spit it out to their audiences and uh
it's really sad how how quick this
misinformation can spread let me blame
putin i mean he's he's russian right
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you